es gibt auch eine neue studie zu den
folgen einer corona infektion die wurde
vorgestellt von der universität
frankfurt und das ergebnis corona
patienten drohen nach einer
überstandenen erkrankung herzprobleme zu
bekommen und genau über diese studie
möchte ich jetzt mit dr thomas aßmann
sprechen
hallo herr assmann berlin ja für wie
glaubwürdig halten denn diese studie für
verlässlich also ich glaube schon dass
man sich da vertrauen und da ist man
darauf vertrauen kann was die kollegen
der in frankfurt raus bekommen haben das
ist auch die erfahrung die wir
mittlerweile gemacht haben
auch die anderen kollegen das zentrale
problem ist dass es ja nicht nur das
herz angegriffen sondern auch ihre
blumen vor allem und manchmal auch sogar
das gehirn das problem ist einfach
dieser virus ist ähnlich wie den
üblichen grippe viren aber aggressiver
auf einen alten bekannten grippe viren
haben wir das muskel entzündungen und so
weiter aber jetzt ist dieser neuen virus
der fraglich noch mehr schäden setzt
oder mehr organe befällt man muss aber
auch sagen 100 patienten ist noch nicht
ganz so viel man muss erstmal eine
langzeitstudie machen sie doch
mindestens ein zwei jahre dauert aber es
weist darauf hin dass wir mit diesem
virus nicht spaßen sollten insbesondere
aufgrund der langzeit schäden die dann
möglicherweise entsteht hier an der
studie wird kann endlichen veränderungen
gesprochen sie hatten es auch gerade
erwähnt wie schlimm sind denn solche
entzündlichen veränderungen am herzen
dann müssen wir einfach ganz einfach in
die pathologie eingeben was heißt dass
der körper erkennt ein virus an unserer
oberfläche jeder videos hat eine gewisse
oberflächenstruktur und der unter dem
grund system greift auf hinzu so und
bekämpfte damit leider manche viren eine
ähnliche struktur wie unser eigener
körper
das bedeutet dass unser eigener körper
anfängt gegen unsere organe seien teil
der organe
möglicherweise eine entzündungsreaktion
eine schutzreaktion zu machen
das bedeutet dass dann sie am herzen zum
beispiel eine myokarditis also eine
herzmuskelentzündung oder so auch an der
herzbeutel cent bekommen und die können
die pumpfunktion also die
leistungsfähigkeit des herzens deutlich
beeinträchtigen
und das ist natürlich richtig unangenehm
und teilweise auch lebensgefährlich und
welche bleibenden schäden drohen noch
nach einer corona infektion da mehr auf
der einen seite die lungenschäden die
schon dokumentiert sind dass der
gasaustausch gar nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert dass das lungenvolumen
eingeschränkt ist bis zu massiven
beschwerden kommen kann
und dann natürlich aber auch
nierenschäden werden sind dokumentiert
worden
und dann was noch nicht hundertprozentig
abgeklärt ist aber wurden die reise auch
geht das auch gedächtnis einschränkungen
da sind intelligenzminderung usw
das auch im bereich des zentralen
nervensystems prozesse ablaufen sind die
nicht positiv sind aber da müssen noch
studien in einer